cette saison dans la flamme 13 femmes
vont devoir se battre pour le coeur d'un
seul homme
activation des petits boutons alors marc
la femme de votre vie vous l'imaginez
comment elle doit être belle je
m'appelle soraya j28 on a very alexandra
je suis juste à la recherche de l'amour
qu'ils aient de la conversation c'est
quoi ta plus grande peur et puis il faut
que tu fasses rien j'aimerais c'est pas
marrant montre là bas vous même pas ce
qu'est ce que vous êtes vous avez deux
lotos des résultats d'accor non pas du
tout voulu souffler dans la bouche suit
pas bien mais l'amour est imprévisible
allez il peut échauffer les choeurs mais
et c'est sûr mais aussi la donne
voler sur son passage le qu'alexandre la
lnah la base suivante c'était gosses non
sentez-vous ridicule et des rythmiques
et tu vas me plais c'est ton pote à
l'eau j'ai foutu pc réactive au genou
gauche et je n'ai pas pu arrêter de me
suivre parmi ces 13 prétendantes
déclara-t-il
sa flamme comment ça va - ouais super et
laventure une catastrophe